[Music]
So why are you guys living in this house? We
live in this house without permission. This is
our home. If you live outside, please take over.
This is the message my parents left me.  It's clearly written that this is what my
late parents left behind for me.
But even if you leave, this is not your place.
[Music] The
true meaning of those words is also mine.  I didn't
understand anything. What if you treasure the things that you don't want to give up now?
Now, how will you act?
Don't look at me without my [music].
In my name, with the power of a talisman, I will bear witness.
Even if my life is worth my while, what does that mean? I was supposed to have
saved her, but if I couldn't save her, there would be no
point in my life until now.
Music]
Damomochi Sanchi no Akashi Joji
Broadcast starts from January 5, 2024
DET